[Música]
Bueno pues después de este reporte de
nuestra enviada especial a Ucrania vamos
con la economía para ello tenemos a
nuestro periodista especializado también
a Juan Pablo lucumí bienvenido de nuevo
acá estamos otra vez en la mesa de
trabajo pues en esta mesa de trabajo
vamos a comenzar hablando de chile que
tiene una noticia muy interesante de la
que vamos a hablar ahora y es ciertas
nacionalizaciones en torno al litio Así
es la Industria Del litio
específicamente un anuncio que no es
para nada poco porque el país
sudamericano quiere ser el productor
número uno del litio y parece que se
está acercando o Pues de conseguirlo ya
veremos con las cifras el jueves el
presidente Gabriel borich presentó su
plan para nacionalizar la Industria Del
litio por medio de la creación de un
modelo público privado para la
explotación de este mineral recordemos
que el litio es usado para fabricar
baterías de almacenamiento de energía de
autos y buses eléctricos y su demanda
creció con fuerza en los últimos años en
momentos en el que el mundo busca
alejarse de los combustibles fósiles
para frenar el calentamiento global así
hizo el anuncio el mandatario
el estado participará en todo el ciclo
productivo de este mineral creando para
ello una empresa Nacional del litio
en segundo lugar el esfuerzo de la
exploración explotación y agregación de
valor lo haremos en base al principio de
colaboración virtuosa público privada
tercero avanzaremos hacia el uso de
nuevas tecnologías de extracción de
litio que minimicen el impacto en los
ecosistemas de los salares Rodrigo y es
que si nos vamos a las cifras chile
ocupa el segundo lugar como productor
mundial de este llamado oro blanco solo
como con Australia superando sus números
y teniendo a China Argentina y Brasil
detrás suyo según el servicio geológico
de Estados Unidos ahora si venimos a
nuestra región rica en materias primas y
commodities con chile Argentina y
Bolivia se conforma al llamado Triángulo
del litio donde está cerca del 60% de
las reservas mundiales de este elemento
y a diferencia del litio australiano que
se extrae en rocas de Minas en el litio
de este triángulo están en salares el
mandatario chileno también dio detalles
de la creación de una empresa nacional
para el oro blanco escuchemos enviaremos
al congreso de la República el proyecto
de ley que crea la empresa Nacional del
litio
esta buscará socios para el desarrollo
de proyectos de agregación de valor y
esto implica ser un esfuerzo adicional
para no solo extraer materia prima sino
convertirla en nuevos productos de alto
valor tecnológico podemos hacerlo en
Chile
entiendo Juan Pablo que el litio va a
ser una moneda de cambio muy importante
para América Latina los próximos años
por lo que decías precisamente por esta
importancia en la nueva economía verde
que se viene hoy desde ya se están
preparando los Las Naciones desde luego
como lo vemos en Chile vamos ahora un
poco más al norte del continente hasta
el Salvador porque tiene nuevas cifras
de inflación pues llegó a su nivel más
bajo la inflación desde octubre 2021
cuando en marzo su tasa interanual
alcanzó el 6,06% desde el 6,82% que
acumuló en febrero según los reportes
del Banco Central de reserva de ese país
los precios se incrementaron entonces en
los alimentos en el sector de bienes y
servicios y en restaurantes y como lo
podemos ver en la Gráfica de tendencia
pues va en descenso y ahora ocupa uno de
los países Pues de América Latina con
menor tasa inflacionaria pues está
interesante esperemos que el resto de
países también sigan esa deflación
inflacionaria vamos a dejar
latinoamérica Nos pasamos a Europa
porque el Ministerio de finanzas de
Francia tiene también una noticia
que han hecho toda esta semana porque la
cartera económica francesa pues ha hecho
importantes anuncios uno de ellos fue el
que hizo ayer que el ministro habló de
que se recortarán muchas de las ayudas
vigentes que el gobierno desplegó desde
la pandemia esto pues para aliviar toda
esta crisis Entonces estos cambios esta
mañana Bruno el ministro de economía
dijo en entrevista con el medio francés
lsi que el escudo de tarifas que pues se
implementó para contener los precios de
Electricidad y gas será eliminado solo
en este último es decir en el gas y que
el escudo seguirá vigente por lo menos
hasta principios de 2025 para que los
elevados precios de la electricidad no
afecten el bolsillo de los franceses
bueno se acaba el invierno en Europa me
imagino que por ahí irá esta noticia
dado que ya se necesitan menos gas van a
reducir un poco el gasto en Francia
vamos ahora con Los indicadores de las
principales bolsas bueno y llegamos con
la noticia de Wall Street porque ya
abrió y abrieron un terreno indeciso
solo con el 500 reportando ganancias el
resto de ellos con pérdidas de menos del
1% las bolsas en nuestra región cerraron
en terreno mixto con el primer balde
Argentina que fue el que cerró con mayor
ganancias del 2,33% Brasil también Tuvo
una leve alza mientras en Colombia y
México sus principales indicadores
tuvieron leves perdidas las bolsas en
Asia cerraron en terreno negativo con el
indicador de Tokio con una pérdida del
0,33% y el de Hong Kong también con una
pérdida de más del 1%. las bolsas
europeas siguen operando sobre todo en
terreno mixto Pues de las bolsas pasamos
a la cifra del día que nos traes son los
2500 millones de dólares que recibió
República Dominicana en remesas entre
marzo entre enero y marzo lo que supone
un incremento del 3,6% con relación al
mismo periodo del año pasado según
informó El Banco Central de ese país
cuál entonces son los países que más
envía dinero a República Dominicana
entre ellos y el tercero es Haití Bueno
pues muy interesante este repaso
económico como siempre ahora sí ya feliz
viernes y que tengas un buen fin de
semana Juan Pablo y nos vemos el lunes
con más economía con mucho más
[Música]